I have got to thank Tank's Good News for this one.
I just love Tank's Good News so much,
and check out this 6 year old skater from Australia.
She recently put on her party dress
and dropped straight into a 12-foot bowl.
Paige Tobin has been skating since she was three
and she wants to go the Olympics one day.
We cannot wait to cheer you on Paige.
I know exactly where you're going
and it's straight to the Olympics.
We get to meet you today though.
Even more importantly, I called the producers
I was like "you guys have to look at this girl!
She's so amazing!"
And guess what, she's here!
Paige Tobin and her mom, Emma!
Hi!
Hello!
(crowd clapping)
Oh my god!
It's so great to be able to say hi to you.
We have seen you do a 12 foot drop
but is it true that you might've even done
a taller one than that?
Yeah. I've done 14-foot
and um, when I jump in,
it feels like I'm flying.
Aww, like you're flying.
I was blown away, when I saw your video.
Now, how did you come into the world of skateboarding?
Did you see something somewhere?
Was it in the neighborhood?
Like what opened your eyes to even try skateboarding?
She was only three when she started.
So when she's asked, if she remembers when she started,
she doesn't remember. (laughs)
Can I ask you question,
if other people are scared of things
what would you tell them?
I'd say, don't, never give up.
I'm, I can't even imagine,
by the way, I just got a skateboard instructor
to start teaching my daughter Olive, Paige.
She's gonna be nine,
and do you have any advice for her?
Um, never give up.
(crowd laughing)
Yup.
So you want to go to the Olympics one day?
Yes.
And if you won Olympic gold,
what would you say in your speech?
You should never give up.
I knew it! That's what I'm saying you worked for,
I love it!
Oh my god.
(host laugh)
Oh Paige, I love you so much!
and Emma, what a great mom, you are.
Thank you.
Thank you, Paige.
You brave brilliant girl. My goodness.
Thank you so much for talking to us today.
Keep it up. Never-
Never give up!
Never give up.
(aughs)
Thanks guys.
Thank you so much.